Okay.
What does this child's game teach us about?
The history of writing something basic but incredibly inventive.
You learned how to write with symbols at Stanford words,
logo,
graphs,
and you saw just how many logo graphs you need to write.
Well,
logo graphs for everything under the sun and the moon,
including the sun and the moon.
But isn't this getting impractical?
Do we really need a symbol for every word?
Surely the madness can't go on forever.
Say hello to this smart rogue who's about to solve your problem with an innocent
mistake.
His father has been counting sheep literally,
and he just asked his son to record a measly line in his budget.
10 sheep for uncle.
The son writes the 10 and the logo graph for sheep,
but uncle,
he pauses and scratches his head.
He go to play with his friends.
He writes the character for ankle 10 sheet ankle.
He hurries away without a second thought,
but don't take his invention lightly.
If you've ever played fill in the blank or guessing games where you have to
sound out picture words you've seen and used this principle for yourself,
but it's not just for quirky puzzles with funny solutions.
The name for this is another major moments in the history of writing.
The name for this is is rebuilt.
This familiar language game lets you look beyond the meaning of a character and
use it simply for its sound son.
Sounds like sun and by extension perhaps soon and sewn logo graphs like the
symbol for Sun could already be read his words now with the Rita's principle in
your pocket,
look at graphs can also be read as sounds.
This isn't just useful for getting ancient uncle his ancient sheep.
Once as tech city planners finished building their stunning capital in the
middle of a lake,
the Venice of the new world,
they know [inaudible].
Their scribes needed a weight of right it's name.
They've been using what amounts to basic picture writing.
Since [inaudible] Tepe learn has a stone tay and a cactus,
naturally it's natural to write it with two fairly obvious glyphs.
Then these become not just symbols,
meaning cactus in stone,
but symbols for the noises they noche de Blonde,
making them just as much rebus fun as those puzzles you solved as a kid and now
you know the name for those.
You also know why there's a cactus on top of a stone in Mexico's flag.
It's not just for show
how alike does a sound like pronunciation have to be,
which sounds can we chop off pit the Egyptians against the Sumerians.
One more time.
Egyptian hieroglyphs cut off the initial consonant or less often two or three
consonants from the original word Sumerians.
On the other hand with their Qa a form take whole syllables.
These two paths don't just add some local flavor.
Reversing out consonants doesn't just impact ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs.
It leaves a legacy for later spinoffs.
The mentality that these either red as Loga graphs or they stand for consonants.
Cuneiform leaves at different legacy,
completely unrelated languages.
We'll spend thousands of years of borrowing and reborrowing cuneiform to write
their own words,
but each time the symbols are red is low.
Good graphs or as syllables.
Flexibility is key here.
Look at this Egyptian hieroglyph.
It can be read as the logo graph for mouth or AA or as the continent or this
character could be read as the logo graph,
meaning house or it could stand for the consonant per the two consonants and the
Egyptian word.
Conveniently in Egyptian,
the little slashy below lets you know when it's a pure logo graph.
The ritas discovery brings up the tension between meaning and sound.
Is Riding phonetic or semantic?
Is it about encoding the meaning of words or encoding?
Speech sounds,
the old logo graphs.
We're fundamentally a meaning writing system.
Sure.
This sounds like ray in Egyptian,
but what's crucial is that this is a logo graph for the word meaning mouth.
Rebus writing takes a big step towards sound writing.
This will come to stand for the continent or regardless of meaning.
It may come as a surprise,
but once discovered,
sound writing doesn't oust meaning writing not at all.
Indeed,
early writers notice that phonetic writing brings up a problem,
a problem you probably missed because of your comfort with sound writing.
A problem that meaning writing can solve.
Brace yourself.
History because Loga graphs are about to make a comeback.
Okay.